I was embroiled in something recently
we're embroiled as pretty as you piss
off that's the real question you got to
say because if you come up to me and
you're like oh I oh I was in bro
ome bro
and then you went Petty with it what
happened when you hear what happened you
gonna say to me
okay [__] that you got embroiled
probably no no problem I get what you're
saying but when you see this you can say
I didn't piss nobody off I'll tell you
right now I'm looking red nice I'm
looking them in the eyes too okay so
I'm gonna show you a video yeah this
video caused this individual a lot of
problems
Ready Set I used to compete in ballroom
dancing
yeah exactly are you guys over here in
this [__] perfect one I haven't done
this so long though wait what kind of
Ballroom what are you doing all the 10
dances I was competing all of them
that's a lot
I haven't done it in years it's a thing
so I'm very curious if I started but
like I I can understand
like if we danced you would be able to
like lead you like yeah exactly really
well because I would probably figure out
like the basic steps and I would figure
out like how to do everything no
[Music]
who the girl his wife
oh it's
his wife his wife
um
Destiny's wife
so they're lesbians yes
[Music]
yes yeah cool we're good Same Love
yeah that's fine okay you see what you
have a problem with lesbian love no okay
do you want to make sure
is that okay yeah
there you go
hey yo you wanna know how to you know
what she was doing she did this she went
that's how I knew man she started
flexing them shoulders and then traps I
was like oh she's not [__] playing
but what's the context okay ready
she's a ballroom dancer and
we danced
and and now everyone's saying he's a
cuck
you mean people that do not dance people
that are not in that dancing world
people that don't know what the [__] is
going on people that win go they go to
the party that's how they dance
people that have not been in this world
people that don't know that in order for
you to get better in that setting of
couple dancing you need to dance with
other people yeah those people they
don't matter okay they just like black
wives
such as nothing sandwich why we even saw
even talk because people are upset about
it and I figured why don't we talk about
it oh you bunch of
two-step having little [__] you don't
know [__] about [__] about that world
shut the [__] up about that [__] okay
you don't know nothing about that
anyways okay sorry about that let's go
back up because I cut you off so go
ahead what were you saying we're talking
to people who may not get it who might
think this is a weird thing say it's
letting someone dance with my wife well
everything is contextual okay everything
is contextual am I just grinding up
behind her in the middle of a club what
am I doing are we line dancing oh my God
you know people are acting like dancing
with somebody the opposite sex is
inherently sexual not knowing you just
haven't been out that's it because if
you go to a Latin club you go to a lot
of Latin countries it's it's normal to
dance with your friend's wife your
friend's mom your mom his grandmother
everything is very respectful of course
there's a way to dance salsa with
somebody you're in love with or
interested in and there's a way to dance
with somebody you're just cool with when
you hold a ballroom setting
this is not sexual no it's what we call
hmm what
it's not sexual but it's what we call a
box
yeah
don't know about this [__] yeah is that
you come in with your frame right you go
like this so you tell the girl or you
put your hands like that to the girl
right depending what kind of dance you
do so he does a lot of salsa I do salsa
uh Bachata kizomba whatever dances are
very close together and you dance with
someone that you don't know I'm
establish a friend with the lady and the
lady is gonna go in see that's where her
back plays so I give her enough space
that if she goes against Mom that's what
I'm gonna say but if she gets closer
that's going to be the the delaying that
she is comfortable with but y'all don't
know nothing about that and it's okay
it's fine calling it a cook you're out
you're out of pocket you're out of line
you're making something out of the thing
that is not a thing right I wanna go
ahead no no so basically that's what it
is so and that's exactly what if you
re-watch the video that's exactly what
you did you went like this your husband
is here I'ma beca there was a lot of
rules that you guys don't know because
you don't know you don't know nothing
about that anyways I'm done go ahead
stupid stupid
it's just so dumb didn't I tell you
though that I didn't piss nobody off
that they just got pissed off oh my days
you know what
in that case
you took that [__] and you ran with it
you actually
that's that's one of the first time that
you were not pity out of all the time
that you delivery piss off people me
included
this time
oh that was not it
I know that was not it actually you did
two things you did not piss nobody off
and in the process you pissed me off
with this dumb [__] yeah buddy that's
why that's genius that's why I let you
rock at the beginning
I knew you were gonna take that [__]
back I knew it that's why I'm like you
know what you know when you're right and
somebody's digging their own grade but
they don't know it because they think
anything in your grave oh
a grave no more
you you got that's not your world not
yours
I think people especially in like the
Western World they just got blinders for
your own cultural experience not
recognize that even within your own
country there's different things in your
city right now there are couples every
single day going out to salsa swing
events and dancing with different
partners the entire night it's not this
overly said I can tell you this I go out
dancing I dance with dozens of women
throughout the entire night I don't
sleep with a single one of them he said
swing events uh not swingers events yeah
like swing accent like the actual dance
swing that you do on Jazz I would highly
recommend you guys get acclimated to
these environments cool thing about
being there is you get constant
proximity to women without a sexual
connotation to it you're just getting
used to just talking to them approaching
them for a dance saying thank you and
then walking away and it's a good way to
kind of break the ice for yourself to
realize like this is not some pedestal
woman that you're like no it's just a
person okay and so for me I'm so
disconnected from that spot I just love
dancing I go out every time I travel I
go to the night out I don't know nobody
when I leave I don't know anybody when I
go I danced with a bunch of strangers
and I go home it's not this I think when
you guys think of dancing you only see
it in the context of a club or a hip-hop
music the last context of dancing you
had was Dirty Dancing the movie that's
what it is yeah that's your last
reference to dance it's important to
know these things aren't the same
Hollywood man yeah and she told me she
was a ballroom dancer in the past I was
like perfect let me check out what you
got that's it
but you know everyone making a big deal
others I'm rolling my eyes I think some
of you guys need to go outside a little
bit more and experience different things
if you're not comfortable with that kind
of thing that's fine you don't have to
be but you can't attribute to it some
kind of intent that's not there
especially when like there's millions of
people who do it every day without that
okay it's like yo I got videos on me on
Instagram dancing with a bunch of people
or Partners who I've had over the years
and guess what I found myself with a
single one of them not everything that
involves the opposite sex involves sex
oh
[Applause]
bro my butt I you you can't even do a
collaboration with a woman without
retards in the comment section who are
like inside virgins or some kind of
weird [__] thinking like y'all banked
there's been times where I've collated
with a woman everybody went oh y'all
bang for sure none of that happened
none of that happened there's not been a
single woman that I've collabored with
online that I've slept with but for you
guys you can't imagine that because men
and women being the same space is
inherently sex
you go to European countries there's
plenty of people who have different folk
dances in the area where they dance with
other people men and women do you think
you see Dancing with the Stars and every
time there's two people dancing they're
banging you know it's funny I mean like
yo yo yo these red pill [__] or
the people around that or people that
sort of have that mentality they're not
red pills but they have the same
direction of mentality you understand
it's the same dude that was calling me
gay back then when I was dancing with
girls because I was dancing with girls
and not doing nothing you're the same
dudes that's fine you're the same dudes
you the same yo you yo you dancing with
girls that's gay what you do I play
football with the boys
you mean to tell me the man tackle
another man is that is
you a fish yo straight dudes you a fish
sometimes straight dudes be doing the
gay [__] looking at everybody else
sideways kingfish
bro learning how to dance crayfish
[Music]
I was really legit looking for some in
their defense I feel like if you sit
there you say I wouldn't want my girl
dancing with other people that's okay
if you guys want to have that
understanding that's fine but what you
can do is look at everyone else who does
it and say oh if you do that it's
because you're inherently this or
whatever I actually you know one of my
favorite Parts back when I dance I dance
with old women young women uh
middle-aged women and this is Joy I
actually love dancing with a lot of the
older women because they have a lot of
experience I mean older I mean like
people in their 60s 70s yeah even though
their movement range isn't great like
yeah buenos I'm telling you right now no
no they know what the [__] they do with
you know what it is you know what
they're good at they make they make the
simple things look good oh yeah yeah
when you when you and she's smiling yeah
[Applause]
there's a fun that that's the thing is
that you rarely communicate with those
people unless it's people in your family
yeah now you're able to just connect
with people like that and they show you
some they show you some they show you
they they job and stuff like that it's
it's just whatever I'm gonna take it a
step higher I'm gonna take it a step
higher but are they gonna understand I
think I'm gonna take a step higher dance
made me come in contact with people I
would have never spoken to ever
definitely people who I would have never
had a single word with all of a sudden
we're dancing we're sharing a beautiful
moment and then we say thank you and we
go our separate ways and that's it but
for those four or five minutes we really
enjoyed each other's company okay and
when I'm meeting a 60 or 70 year old you
know Latin woman who
doesn't speak any English but she
accepts a dancer we both smile and enjoy
yourself it's like bro we're defying
even the language barrier
I was so I was in Russia
yeah
it's a bird yeah
yeah music and I'm like oh
oh I trained my whole life for this
I don't know what the [__] you talking
about but I went oh I told my two boys I
was like yo I don't know what the hell
you guys doing but I'm going over there
I went there and I dance with people
that spoke nothing but Russian yeah and
we was able to speak yeah they were just
like that's too crazy yeah you couldn't
got to go yeah yeah all them is get the
[__] NATO what the [__] out one two
three and five six seven everybody knew
that one two three five six seven it
don't matter where you're from yeah it's
just anyways whatever it was like and
you knew that that good thing and you
hear whipper yo listen
I don't even know there's some things
that I don't have to explain you get it
or you don't yeah but calling someone
cook or whatever what not you guys are
lame for that it's okay I want delicious
to be able to talk about the benefits of
that so like you you even look from
study standpoint how good it is for your
health for your mentality and honestly
I'll say this too I know this is going
out to socials often even going to clubs
land clubs or whatever
I noticed that for the old people who go
it is like the highlight of their week
yeah because you can tell like for them
their social life probably isn't the
most expensive but when they go out
dancing two three times a week for them
it gets their bodies moving which is
great for their health but also for
their spirit because they're interacting
with people a community you know as we
go through life and everybody becomes
more separated kids get older folks move
away we become more isolated dance
communities really offer a lot they
offer a lot they offer you an
opportunity to bond with humans which is
like one of our basic human needs and so
yeah I don't know I when I think about
it now
dance has given me friends uh it's
giving me communities it's given me
family uh it's given me Health it's
given me so many beautiful things I
think during the pandemic when that got
taken away from me I didn't realize how
much I suffered till I got it back so
yeah
whatever they want to say about this
that's fine but again maybe there's just
more experiences for you guys to check
out and learn from and you're missing
out and it's okay that you're missing
out yeah anything else no
that's such a nothing Burger bro have
you guys enjoyed today's video be sure
to like comments